joining us now is former trump
impeachment lawyer doug david shone and
harmeet dillon chairwoman of the
republican national lawyers association
david
tonight the washington post published
the latest leaks from the biden doj
um all of this is feeling uh a little
familiar to me how about you
yeah of course uh listen it's a complete
uh political partisan weaponization of
the process and it's a very scary thing
because this is a process in which you
know the courts for decades have said we
have to have a neutral and detached
magistrate overseeing things if we can't
trust this process
we're in a lot of trouble not just when
a president's records are seized but you
know all of us are in danger if we can't
trust the integrity of the process once
it becomes politicized we're all in a
heap of trouble
so on this column that rivkin uh david
rivkin uh wrote harmy
about the legal basis uh underlying this
raid this search warrant your thoughts
on that given the presidential records
act issue
well it was a very interesting piece by
rivkin and casey and they essentially
said that no matter what this search
warrant said the presidential records
act provides very broad protection for
former presidents to take these papers
and it goes through how
uh there are uh five to up to 12 years
that a president working in conjunction
with the archives can keep the public
from seeing these papers but what's
important is that the statute
does not specify the time place and
manner of the handover of those
documents to the archives and so here
the archives are effectively using the
doj
and the fbi is their goons to get these
papers back they're not entitled to
these papers and in fact other
presidents including obama have gone
through the same process they're keeping
these documents from the public and
they're you know taking their sweet time
so why is trump being treated
differently i think we all know why and
i think that uh the fact that there are
evolving justifications and also nightly
leaks about this process also underlines
this is purely political in nature and
not about any important government
records yeah i mean david
to stay on this issue of the leaks for a
moment
we are supposed to believe
that the fbi and the doj
are acting in good faith without
political bias or retribution for anyone
including the former president of the
united states
how do these leaks do anything but
undercut that and if not then why
doesn't merrick garland
get up before cameras tomorrow and say
these leaks have got to stop
we're going to find out who did this and
they're going to be subject to whatever
you know punishment or
legal uh ramifications
that are possible here well isn't he
outraged by this yeah right you're 100
right and of course he should however i
have to say i think that today at least
half the company country wouldn't
believe him if he said it he came out
and said in this case and in the bannon
case this reflects the equal application
of the laws no reasonable person really
believes that this raid on president
trump's compound was the equal
application of the laws and by the way i
think this lack of confidence in the
justice department really makes the
so-called taint team or filter team
process problematic you know in 2019 the
fourth circuit said that this process
isn't appropriate anyway you know this
process is supposedly having a
segregated team from the prosecution
team reviewing documents at the end of
the day they're still their same doj
colleagues and so the fourth circuit
said it's the improper allocation of
judicial function to the executive
branch and that's why one of the reasons
this special master has been requested
here although you know i'm a little
disappointed that they waited so long to
request it that was the obvious move in
this case we saw it in giuliani and in
other cases that's what has to be done
in the old days we might have asked for
a special you know filter team or a
taint team but with this
politicalization you cannot have that in
this justice department harming yes or
no was it too late to file this special
master motion i mean it's being kind of
pooh-poohed by people but i don't think
it's too late
well i agree with david's comments i
mean in timing earlier could have been
better but there may be good reasons why
they didn't but in any event right now
having that in place will allow if it
were granted the special master to
re-review redesignate if necessary
segregate claw back give back and do all
of that under the scrutiny of a district
court judge and so i do think that
that's important it needs to be done
here um judge cannon i think apparently
got this got this case by uh by random
draw and so you know let's see what she
does with it let's see what happens
later this week yeah she seems to be
fair-minded by all accounts david and
harmeet thank you both tonight hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else